normally referendum question should be
pretty simple things should Scotland be
an independent country yes or no but in
the case of the Greek referendum while
you can see here it hardly be more long
or complicated let me just read out a
translation should the plan of agreement
be accepted which was submitted by the
European Commission the European Central
Bank and the International Monetary Fund
in the Eurogroup of the 25th of jun 2015
and comprises of two parts which
constitute their unified proposal the
first document is entitled reforms for
the completion of the current program
and beyond and the second preliminary
debt sustainability analysis no or yes
to make matters even more complicated
the whole document itself is extremely
long difficult even for economists and
it's no longer valid so not a simple
question and no simple answers either
whether it's a yes or a no the truth is
it's going to be an uphill struggle to
work out what the consequences are
really going to be and that's difficult
for the people here who just want to
know are the bank's going to open on
Monday or Tuesday probably not either
way is this going to go from being a
cash economy back to one way you can
borrow and is it going to stay in the
Euro if Greece did leave the euro
economist think the drachma the new
drachma would fall by as much as fifty
percent now in theory that evaluation
should be pretty good news for exports
the problem for Greece is that it's not
very reliant on exports only
thirty-three percent of its economy
comes from trade compare that to forty
six percent in Germany's case or over
fifty percent for Iceland which also had
a big devaluation off to its crisis in
the end the question of whether Greece
stays in all leaves the euro will come
down to the banking system which
billions of euros has been coming out of
over the course of the past few weeks
they say they only have 1 billion euros
left that equates to just 90 euros per
person and finally there's what Yanis
varoufakis the finance minister calls
the elephant in the room Greece's 323
billion euros national debt higher than
almost anywhere else in the developed
world if they left the euro they might
be able to default on that but that's
not a foregone conclusion if they stayed
in the IMF says that you should write
off about 50 billion of it anyway but
Germany doesn't want that because it is
the biggest owner as you can see
no simple question and certainly no
simple answers